so now for this last example underneath
Exponential's this is actually kind of a
sneaky one because in fact we are not
going to be integrating at all look
carefully and you'll see why the
question says use the trapezoidal rule
with five function values to approximate
the area between the curve and the
x-axis from x equals 1 to x equals 3
give your answer correct to 4 decimal
places all right boy there's a lot to
take in here so let's just take it one
step at a time the first thing is the
question says use the trapezoidal rule
now let's remember this is a method for
trying to find an area and well let's
find it close to an area when you can't
actually integrate that thing directly
or when integrating that thing directly
is an excessive amount of work and we
just need something close that'll be
good enough now if you look closely at
the function that they're actually
handing to us y equals e to the power of
1 or X this is a good example of a
function that we do not know how to
integrate a man will be possible but we
don't have access to that knowledge no
problem we can actually still use the
trapezoidal rule to get and approximate
the result like they're saying over here
on the right hand side now the next
piece of information in here that it
needs to be paid attention to is this
crucial phrase here five function values
now we were posing this question before
and with our previous lessons when we
are all told to use the trapezoidal rule
how many trapeziums are we supposed to
use to find out the area like when we
get told the answer is absolutely you
will be told sometimes you know you want
to get a specific amount of accuracy so
you have to work that out yourself but
in in 99.9% of the situation's you're
going to encounter they just hand you
here's the number of you know
applications of the rule that we want or
as you can see in this particular
question they'll give you the number of
function values they want now I want to
call you mind back to when we were
looking at trapezoidal rule let me just
dig back into my notes here here's the
trapezoidal rule right now remember what
are the function values well when you
have a look at the trapezium that you
use to approximate the area the function
values are these vertical lines that are
parallel to each other and they form the
two parts that go into up here they go
into the area of a trapezium formula
right so if I use some let's find a
really obvious color here if I use a
color like green you can see here's the
first function value he's the second
function value I've got two function
values when I have one trapezium if I
keep on going here you can see I've
highlighted these in green when I tried
our two trapezius to get more accurate
I had three function values three
function values for two trapeziums and
to just do one more example here again
highlighted in green for you i've got 1
2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 function values for a
trapezium so in other words you've
always got one more function value then
you have trapezium so when we come down
here this question whoops we passed it
this question says 5 function values so
that's another way of saying using for
trapeziums or for applications of the
trapezoidal rule another way you could
think about it is you could draw the 5
function values if I had something like
here's a function value here's another
function value here's another one here's
another one and the final one over here
there's five vertical lines and if I
join up all of the tops there you can
see there are your four trapeziums 1 2 3
& 4 so that's a lot to take in right but
now we're pretty much ready to actually
begin the question now what I'm going to
do is I'm going to rehearse for you what
is the trapezoidal rule for five
function values well I'm going to call
my function values why not
y1 y2 y3 and y4 you might recall that we
start off counting at zero so that the
final value matches up with a number of
trapeziums that we've got so I can say
the area is going to be equal to
approximately and now let's see if we
can remember the formula it's H on 2
where H is the height of each of the
trapeziums you know it'll be maybe this
distance here right that distance there
they're all the same that'll be our
height
H on 2 and then what we multiply by is
the first function value the last
function value and then we double all
the ones in the middle remember we're
doubling the ones in the middle because
each one gets used twice it gets used by
the trapezium on its left and the
trapezium on its right so you know over
here
say this function value in here right in
the middle it gets used once by this
trapezium and it gets used once by this
trapezium so that's why we use it twice
so therefore noting that I've got my
particular names of my function values
up here in the top the first one will be
y0 the last one will be y4 and then i
get double all the ones in the middle
which is y1 y2 and y3 so now I've got my
area my trapezoidal rule formula for the
area set up I need to know what are all
the things that I'm going to substitute
into here okay now none of the values
that I need to substitute into this are
actually in the question directly but I
will use the question to actually get
them I'm thinking about the X values
that correspond to these Y values the
way I'm going to get them is to find out
where a long have I passed within my
domain Kia so just came back to this
example that I did over here it's got
the same number of function values that
we want so if I just use this as our
little market here right the question
tells us that we're going to start at x
equals 1 and then end x equals 3 so that
is my start and my end and you can see
from 1 to 3 if I'm breaking it up into 4
trapeziums I need 4 equal height going
along so there's a total distance of 2
if I'm breaking that up into chunks into
4 chunks then each of those chunks is
going to be 1/2 1/2 plus 1/2 plus 1/2
plus 1/2 will give me that total
distance along the x-axis of 2 so if
that's 1/2 the first thing I know is oh
this is the value that's going to go
into H that is the height of each of the
trapeziums that's good and then secondly
it also tells me where the function
values are doesn't tell me what they are
equal to
but it doesn't does tell me the X values
that correspond to them I've got I've
already said one and three they're my Y
naught and my Y 4 and then all I need to
do is progress half a unit every time
let's go back to green now this one in
here I sure don't need her as there will
be one point five this one in here will
be two and then this one on here will be
two point five so you can see those
values in there each time I'm
progressing half half half half and then
up I'd go so one of the helpful ways to
make sure you do all this substitution
correctly which some people find useful
is to draw a table okay
now this is not necessary and I'll show
you how to do this in a second without
it and but is really helpful to make
sure you get all of your values correct
right so what I can do is I can say for
each of the X values I'm going to get a
corresponding Y value don't forget that
the Y values are e to the one on X so
therefore in my let me make a bit of a
table here no why am I gonna go
something like that
should do me let's see if we can fit it
in okay I'm going to say my x values are
one one point five to two point five and
three and now I'm going to calculate
what the Y values are that corresponds
to those just be careful when you're
doing your substitution here and
obviously you're going to need your
calculator to help you this will be e to
the power of 1 over 1 so that'll be in
the power of 1 this will be e to the
power of 1 on 1.5 you can see what I'm
doing is I'm substituting into the
definition of the function
I'll have e to the power of 1/2 e to the
power of 1 over 2.5 and then e to the
power of 1/3 once you've got each of
these they are what you're going to
substitute into Y naught y 4 y - y1 y2
and y3 okay so what I've got is I'm
going to have this is approximately
equal to 1/2 on - that's going to be
equal to 1/4 and then in here I'm going
to put in all of my values now what I've
actually done is I've got my calculator
already and I've evaluated what these
are - here my values over
here and you can see I've actually
worked out the final answer down the
bottom but we'll get to that shortly so
don't do that let's just come back up
the top okay now what I've got here for
my values is everything here to whatever
number of decimal places like 10 or 11
or something like that now the reason
why I've written these is because I
actually want to see those numbers on
the working of you know whoever's mark I
work I'm actually looking at so when I'm
marking that way I know the four for
processing that the students actually
done the work and also if something has
gone wrong in the students working I can
also backtrack and find out what was the
nature of their error the reason why
this is so important to emphasize right
now is that at this point most of you
will just reach for your calculator and
you may well go ahead and put this
entire line in and you just get a number
at the end if that number is wrong and
you just write that final number it's
really really hard to work out what on
earth actually went on behind the scenes
because all disguise by the calculator
so what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna take
all of these values over here in the my
working on the right hand side and I'm
gonna substitute them into my lines so
let's see here I'll do a few decimal
places so I've got e to the 1 is 2.718 a
to the 1/3 is 1.39
looks like it's a 6 what that's gonna
round 2 plus 2 lights off okay I'm gonna
put that on the next likes I think I'm
probably not gonna fit - lots of y1
where's that that's in a pair of 1 over
1.5 so that's one point nine four eight
y2 is one point six four nine plus the
final one well it's actually the third
one but I've already written down the
final one it's one point four nine -
isn't it okay
so there we go now even though I have
rounded off clearly in this line I've
rounded off to three decimal places when
I'm actually punching this on my
calculator I'm going to actually use the
exact values that the calculator has
evaluated and the reason for that of
course is every time you round off for
example I'm here I rounded this is one
point three nine six I rounded up by a
point zero
0:04 um this one I think I also rounded
up by point zero zero zero three I
rounded up a bunch of times and I'm also
multiplying by two so eventually all
those things kind of gather together and
they are going to make my answer off by
a little bit perhaps by a significant
figure so that's why you can see what
I've actually done is I've gone and
evaluated at precisely using my
calculator and that's given me this
value you can see right down the bottom
three point five seven two six one three
I'm actually going to write my entire
calculator display here and the reason
why is because that way if I
approximating correctly some questions
the approximation we're looking at that
we're actually marking we assign a whole
mark to it but often we don't because
your approximate all the time and we not
going to deduct your mark every single
time because you you'd lose a lot of
marks if you didn't know how to do this
one skill so therefore I'm putting the
exact value in and then when I go to the
question I can get rid of this
calculator now I'm gonna go to the
question it says give your answer
correct to four decimal places now I
will actually do the rounding so I will
say it's three point five seven three in
fact
I'll go one better than that at this
point I'm ready to conclude remembering
that I was trying to find an area right
so I'm going to say therefore the area
is I should write the word approximately
because this is an approximation
approximately and this is where I also
include my units rather than in the
process of doing the working above so
the unit's don't just appear out of
nowhere
so whoo take a deep breath that was a
lot of work because this is a very
involved question but remember all the
steps that feed into this a very logical
it's like a cow I kind of integrate this
so I'm gonna use the trapezoidal rule
how am I going to use the trapezoidal
rule they specify the number of
trapeziums
you have to find out where they go so
that was us finding out our different X
values and the function values or Y
values that go with that you can use a
table to help you make sure you
logically set it out and not miss any
numbers or miss type them and then
carefully go to calculator do an
evaluation show us that working is you
go through and then conclude
with your area